while you belle ste notizie tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vj scusatemi se non urlo come una
[ __ ] argomento di video però siamo in
treno e devo mantenere un certo contegno
poi c'è capri che legge le notizie
qui non posso disturbarlo e niente
volevo dire finisco in un secondo e
finisco promesso siamo ragazzi sul nuovo
best of di social facebook
la giulietta
auguriamo buona visione stiamo andando a
roma noi stiamo facendo le cose belle
mark hanna mia
la manda a casa se l'avete capito amanda
ha contrae piacevole zio fester
geniale ha capito mi piace mi lascia più
non sai guida ma queste vicende guidarti
si dice come faccio a dirlo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
minuti nella grand prix super smash
questo andiamo
come eravamo già sacchi parte parte bene
la bella ragazza ma che cosa ti volti
come sono competitive e competitiva ma
cosa sta affidando a caso perché anche
sabrina per essere la donna che ha
guidato benissimo è più o meno ma mi sa
che cosa è quello che arrivato ultimo
dei quali ancora per poco lui esulta
francesco determinare cosa che faccio
il papa
[Musica]
cosa dopo un quarto d'ora bravo e la
curva io ho preso dal panico contro
aspettato aspettato aspettato che non
capivo che si faceva andare davanti
chiti di supero ragazzi fatti male da
due però impero quando c'e la supremazia
v'aspetta fa vedere insulti che ti hanno
fatto passa di mano a schiantare piccola
sonora tv marchigiani stanno mettendo
d'accordo ma io sono lì in fondo e
portandole cavolo sei giocoli formando
tranquillo chi va piano va sano e va
lontano
proviamo così ogni natale la strada con
tanto di davis e poi non è giusto giusto
perché volevo vedere cose in faccia ecco
lo stato come solo che ho fatto io ma
l'hai fatta poi mi sono sbagliato e
quindi il replay
mi aspetto anche lui in tutto ciò la
sfida finale della famiglia no no no no
c'è il colpo di scena della ricerca il
po di scena incredibile noi rimasti gli
stessi
chi è quello attenzione parigi contro sa
se il primo di no ma chi no perché sasha
a curvare io no ma faceva pane tipo
tocchi uno dei brace
adesso ci vedi che siamo testa a testa
adesso c'è colpo di grazia ha colpito
sabrina recupera posa come è possibile
sapere la fermana partito di un giro
sempre in a te lo giuro che succede
qualcosa forse a doppiavo non ricordo
bene ma rimane niente volevo fare
l'ingegnere calma
mi fanno scattare e arrivò secondo di
teschi del senato
questo io sono coerente quello non ha la
patente ragazzi c'è un problema di fondo
io non lo sapevo
secondo nuova fase di cosa se c'e cosa
sono io il migliore degli stormtrooper
coppa in faccia prima previdenza
chiamami vedere qui sei tranquillo no
non sono tranquillo e non lottiamo tutti
nel senso che vedete che non è
tranquillo lo noto che mi ha [ __ ] il
telefono abbiamo preso una scatola nera
e dentro abbiamo inserito il cellulare
di lorenzo l'abbiamo fatto credere però
che in quella scatola c'è un essere
particolare non abbiamo specificato se
si trattasse di un ragno di qualsiasi
altro animale la fobia prigione di fare
come di annotare la sudorazione come
canne dall'inizio alla fine
io vengo per terra se un ragno ok svengo
veramente per terra annunciato poi solo
mettere la mano è ricordati è
sicuramente preferire mettere la mano in
una scatola piena di di fiamme cose
allora siamo e di cosa sta preoccupando
si pensa ci fosse una tarantola mia ex
professoressa
e lei e lui trovato
dov'era il telefono e lanciarono
purtroppo non c'era niente sei felice
delle persone meschine hai superato la
tua paura abbiamo iniziato con calma e
si arriva una peggiore per renderlo un
po più felice punterei su un bel colore
sgargiante quanto è un'usanza automatico
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che queste non son penitenze senso
legali non l'ha mai vista
perché ci ho fatto il click day armi di
difesa 2017 ragazzi
ciò che resta è meglio nei capelli veri
di oliva del ciccio gamer
ho però tutto sommato non è così male ma
solo a me sembra che la steel clown e
imperfetti del fuoco per colorarsi tipo
tudor e invece lui no è un riavuti pure
gratis oggi
intenso perfetta è sempre di macchine si
parlano
la patente volete fare queste verifiche
fare questo ai 270
basta glielo spiego massima che poi sono
in vacanza
[Musica]
che cosa
hai detto questa cosa non è stato
accettato perché
[Musica]
vabbè però darà figo almeno questa è la
penitenza migliore della serie x ma
guardiamola però non voglio sperare che
prima d'ora
siamo nella tua fidenza in questa è una
penitente aspettava dei valori è ferita
di buttare colpacci già ben motivato
grazie papà per il tanto che aiuta ma
mai al city fuori cioè vi siete quelli
erano 152 metri di vuoto
8 io abito al terzo piano ci diano
respiro proposti guarda in affari
io sono tutto capace sfida che poi lui
dice vita e lo conosci lato di butti the
meno che va benissimo lì ma vai così fa
male sapere quanti vincita un motivatore
per quello visto buttare a prezzo che
abbiamo più paura noi di lui secondo me
il piano chiaro che dietro la vita ruota
la luna lontano un piano piano con i
piedi piano piano con i piedi ancora
avanti ancora l'anti perfetto così ma la
capella le braccia mi ogni volta noi che
contiamo
ora
la vagina
[Musica]
quando te lo guardate la grazia di non
permettere che mal di testa
dai che si concluda la tua buttato la
ferita è piaciuta io ringrazio lei
comunque tutto il pubblico da casa che
ci ha seguito dall'inizio fino a che ci
sta lasciando a lui continui aspetti che
mi piace ma e vi invitiamo a seguire la
prossima data va bene ma delle belle
vedremo delle belle
[Musica]